[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates gone
girl the American Board college student
who left Alabama to become an Isis bride
and called for Americans to be killed
now she wants to come home with her
toddler son but my future and my son's
future no but the Trump administration
says she won't be allowed back
she is not a US citizen nor is she
entitled to US citizenship and what
about the journalists that were captured
still missing in Syria John Canty lay
Austin Tice will be joined by the mother
of journalist James Foley who was taken
hostage by Isis and then murder
plus our shoutout the reporters in Tampa
who investigated a prestigious
Children's Hospitals Heart Institute
your daddy just suffered a stroke
[Music]
three times the normal death rate a
child left paralyzed another with a
needle left in her chest yeah in many
ways these were families who didn't have
a voice from the law and crime Network
studios in New York City this is Brian
Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight as US and Allied forces
close in on one of the last Isis
strongholds there's this question of
who's left alive and what to do with
them several of the young Americans who
turned their backs on their country and
went to join Isis have already returned
or had been captured and are being held
in Syria among them a young college
student who sneaked away from her
parents in Alabama to become an Isis
bride at the height of the ISIS reign of
terror targeting American hostages four
brutal executions taking credit for
attacks in the US and elsewhere of
innocent civilians then 20 year-old
Hold'em Athena a college student in
Alabama chose to become one of the
dozens of Americans to join up with the
terror group she sneaked away from her
family and settled in the Syrian city of
Raqqa the Isis headquarters and married
an Isis fighter from Australia suhan
Rahman who would be the first of three
different Isis men she would marry in a
tweet using the name of jihad who
thought a post to the picture of four
passports and wrote bond fire soon no
need for these anymore then after her
husband Rahman was killed the American
convert sent this message by Twitter in
2015 veterans Patriot Memorial etc Day
parades go on drive-bys spill all of
their blood or rent a big truck and
drive all over them kill them now four
years later Hoda mafada is one of 1500
Isis wives and children being held in
this refugee camp in Syria and she wants
to come home with her 18 month old son
launching a media campaign to express
her regrets I don't know I think I
thought I was doing things correctly for
for
sake of God and when I came here and I
saw everything with my own eyes I
realized that I made a big mistake and I
know I ruined my future and my son's
future and I'm she says she wants to
come home when I go back I will learn
more and I will try to help people not
make the same mistake that I have do you
think you'll be able to go back to the
United States do you want to go to the
United States
I prefer America other than anywhere
else yeah and what do you what do you
want to do if you went back to the
States what do you think will happen to
you if you were didn't allowed to go
back of course I'll be given jail time
on instructions from President Trump the
State Department has issued a ruling
that Hold'em leuphana is not considered
a US citizen and will not be allowed to
return to the United States she is a
terrorist she's not a US citizen she
ought not return to this country sir she
wasn't born here she may have been born
here she is not a US citizen nor is she
entitled to US citizenship her case is
not the first and likely would not be
the last to involve Isis fighters and
supporters who want to return to their
homeland
now that the terror group has been
largely defeated or at least had the
territory yet held in Syria overrun by
US and Allied forces joining us now
three people who know a lot about this
three people for whom I have great
respect Karin Greenberg is the director
of the Center on national security at
the Fordham Law School Seamus Hughes is
the deputy director of the program on
extremism at George Washington
University and coming into us by Skype
from Boston is Diane Foley whose son
James was a freelance journalist taken
hostage and then executed by Isis let me
start with you miss Foley what do you
think should happen with Hoda well I
think it's very important that any and
all of the Isis fighters see they why
the borders of the terrorists activity
must be held accountable I think it's
essential otherwise I feel that the
surviving fighters will become
emboldened to just bring their terrorism
alpha women
I feel it's very important however I
realize it's complex and perhaps it
requires an International Criminal Court
if not possible to bring her and others
in the United States for justice would
you prefer that she be brought here and
put on trial I feel she should be held
accountable for sure it's essential
I just president's apology directive
which promised that whenever American
citizens are killed are harmed in any
way that we would hold them accountable
and we have two of this alleged Beatles
Cody and upstate awaiting extradition in
Syria awaiting for someone to hold them
accountable for their crimes so let me
ask you Seamus you've been tracking this
as well in the case of Hoda you were
telling me the decision to strip her of
her citizenship or not recognize her as
citizen was made in the previous
administration the Obama administration
they decided to revoke her citizenship
or at least look at the citizenship and
decide that she wasn't a US citizen to
begin with so it really wasn't president
Trump's call no in many ways the Trump
administration is for furthering the
Obama administration's decision and I
don't think it's the correct decision
Karen Greenberg what do you say about
that I think that we have very strict
rules about stricking us taking
someone's citizenship away revoking it
in any way and that crossing this
threshold is unacceptable and I think
the issue of stripping citizenship and
holding somebody accountable via trial
are separable and that I agree that we
need to hold her accountable in a court
of law here as we've done for many
citizens and non-citizens alike Seamus
how many Isis supporters loyalists had
been brought back to the u.s. how many
went I'm gonna your back yeah so the FBI
talks about some 300 people that have
attempted to or have traveled to Syria
in Iraq in terms of folks that have come
back from isis-controlled territory 16
Americans that we've identified and of
that 16 we prot
two to 13 this is a well-worn system of
putting them through federal court
systems there's a way to deal with
classified information there's a way to
get justice to the families and victims
in here and there's a way to figure this
out so there's no need to send them to
Guantanamo no I don't think so in many
ways you know in Guantanamo we're still
waiting for the first trial and if you
want to get justice I think the federal
court system is the way to go Karen do
you agree with that yeah I also want to
point out that in the filings that her
lawyers put forth contesting her the
issue of citizenship they made it very
clear that she was willing to face any
charges that would be leveled against
her so I think this also goes to the
issue of how valuable her citizenship is
and how seriously we should take that
and the issue here is that her father
was a diplomat supposedly at the time
she was born so if he was then she
wouldn't be given apparently she was
more if the facts we know are correct as
alleged in court papers she was born
after he was fired from the State
Department he had been on a diplomatic
visa the question is was he still on
that diplomatic visa or not and if he
was then she wouldn't be granted
citizenship but remember she was given a
passport twice in 2005 and again in 2014
so this the the problem with this is
that there has been a push against US
citizenship in favor of D naturalizing
more people of rethinking how we define
citizenship since the beginning of the
Trump presidency and we've seen it now
with the Census whether or not you have
to declare citizenship on census and in
other areas and so it's very
disconcerting and worrisome Seamus you
began tracking this many years ago
you've talked to her parents three or
four years ago what led heard actually
end up going to Syria to join Isis
become one of these Isis Brides yeah I
think this is one of those cases one of
the very few cases where the online
environment played a huge role in her
radicalization
she reached out to a series of Isis
recruiters online she got contact with
them she had a very strict upbringing
her father was you know restrictive
phones didn't let her date boys and
things like that and she wanted a sense
to get out of that and so in the middle
of the night she told her parents she
was gonna go see a college and the next
day she disappeared and they've been
just like that just like that and that's
the you know the story of most of the
ISIS cases in America you have kind of
bystanders you see something but they
don't realize what they're seeing so if
the US Department ruling holds she is a
stateless person and so is her son yeah
and that's and that's the issue it's
it's that gray area right now
you know we've repatriated about nine
children so far back to the US there's a
system to deal with this but I don't
think the sins of the mother should be
the sins of the son and we have to
figure out a way to do this Diane Foley
how do you feel about that is this the
appropriate way to handle it she should
have brought back her child given US
citizenship the child should be
protected certainly he's an innocent
victim of all of this but I think it's
very important that we remember not just
this young woman but also the hundreds
of thousands of people the Isis fighters
have held and the fact that for American
citizens were kidnapped tortured and
killed by these fighters and if I really
feel it's in our interest to find a way
to hold all of them accountable be it
through an international court or our
own dust system but I feel it's
essential or we will be very sorry
because they will come back and bring
more terror to our countries in a
different way different planes so I feel
it's essential as you mentioned the
so-called beetles the Isis militants who
held your son and others - four of them
have now been captured being held what's
going to happen with them Seamus it
appears that that they'll be brought
back to the Eastern District of Virginia
and face federal charges I think the
jury is still out about that the UK's
there's a series of Appeals that the
mother is making now but I think in the
end of the day they will face justice
and not in the u.s. court system and at
least I hope including the possibility
of the death penalty that's still in the
table appears yeah a question for our
control room Rhonda Schwartz executive
producer Rhonda what's your question a
question from the control room
there was a case of another woman she
also was a bride
Isis she married an Isis fighter he died
in battle but she's back in the United
States in Indiana I think she had three
children who are now in foster care what
about those children what about the next
generation of children who were in Isis
now back in the United States should we
worry about those kids have you been
tracking that rings so Sam was was found
in a refugee camp with their children
she was eventually repatriated the US
and faced material support of terrorism
charges she's facing about at least 20
years now the children ended up in
Indiana Child Protective Services and my
concern there is that that you know
Indiana Child Protective Services does
not understand the concerns of PTSD of
radicalization of these children being
in war zones we haven't set up a
systematic way to deal with with
children's Isis and that's true of the
US but it's also true of the UK France
Germany these are things that we haven't
grappled with it so Western countries is
their concern let me ask you Diane Point
is there concern that these children and
others may be the next generation of
possible terrorists well certainly this
ideology is very strong anyone who was
part of it was indoctrinated brainwashed
became part of them so what of course
depends on the age of the child and but
I agree with Seamus that if the child is
older and most of these children have
seen incredible destruction of violence
they need special care for sure they
need to be monitored and and receive you
know the counseling and proper clear
that they require and Karen Greenberg is
Isis still a threat to people in this
country this is still a vibrant ideology
so I want to talk about the child do but
I will answer this first look we know
that the the policy of the United States
was to push this threat abroad we
succeeded in doing that over two
administrations and the threat in this
country has been diminishing for a long
time now
a handful of cases in 2018 and so and
most of them had nothing to do with
threatening attacks nearly all of them
in the United States so it's much less
than it ever was
who knows what can happen in the future
but I want to talk about this child
issue the issue of children of Isis
fighters is a serious issue there there
are camps of Isis families in
Afghanistan in Syria as you mentioned
and elsewhere these children sometimes
have have mothers sometimes do not and
they are left in a state of general
untended 'no sin terms of Education in
terms of understanding what faces them
in the world and so while we're focusing
on these three in Indiana which is fine
the the crisis of children worldwide in
stateless situations is is something
that is extremely essential to
understand if you care about the
national security of the United States
and the globe and the problems even
greater overseas is it not a kingdom
absolutely and in in France alone you
have 130 children that they're concerned
about in terms of returning and what to
do with them and finally we just have a
minute Diane Foley there are other
Americans Westerners still being held by
Isis it's thought well we're not sure
but I know of two public faces of
Americans who are being held in Syria
the most well-known of course is Austin
Tice who's been held since August 2014
and there's a gentleman a gentleman that
I've recently come to know Jamil palamas
who was taken in Damascus he's the site
psychologist who was working there with
refugees but I've been working most
closely with the Tice family but more
recently with this second gentleman and
we have no idea where they are and who
has them Diane thank you very much the
issue continues I want to thank you
Karen Greenberg Shawna's Hughes for
joining us this evening you
your insights help us to better
understand this highly charged issue
next our shout out for the reporters who
uncovered the heartbreaking scandal of
children dying at a facility run by one
of the country's most prestigious
hospitals at three times the normal rate
of death
our shout out tonight to an
investigative team at the Tampa Bay
Times that got a tip from a Children's
Hospital about a personnel change
crunched a huge download of medical data
and discovered children in a special
heart surgery unit were dying at a rate
that far exceeded any other Hospital in
the state the investigative report with
its own video was aptly named heart
broken at least 11 children dead in one
18 month period many others left
paralyzed or otherwise harmed surgeons
actually left a needle inside this
girl's heart and never told her parents
[Music]
you can be the best hands in Florida and
we find that there was in fact the
needle in her chest and after the
surgery was over when they did the count
they have to do to make sure they have
all the utensils and everything they
were missing a needle so they knew they
were missing the needle but they never
said anything to us it was that
troubling story that the reporters at
the Tampa Bay Times say made them
certain they were onto something big I'm
Kathleen McCrory I'm the deputy
investigations editor for the Tampa Bay
Times and I'm Neal Betty I am an
investigative reporter for the temp of a
times the reporters say the initial tip
came from someone who worked at the
Children's Hospital which had been taken
over by the prestigious Johns Hopkins
Medical Center its promotional videos
boast of a world-class reputation they
came in and told us that she had truncus
arteriosus they told us we'd be going to
Johns Hopkins all Children's
[Music]
they just kept telling us that there
wasn't a story here for a little while
and that they had self police themselves
out of their problems so there was no
point in us further investigating or
researching what was going on but
McGrory and Biddy ignored all that and
dug deeper into what happened at the
hospitals Heart Institute after Hopkins
had taken over after that happened there
started to be some some serious clinical
issues in the program and that meant
that children were dying at a much
higher rate and there were far more
complications than this program was used
to it had tripled to about nine or ten
percent and that was the highest rate of
any program in Florida that we had seen
for the past decade and then using
social media as a starting point the
reporters began to hear from families
whose children had been at the Heart
Institute it was incredibly emotional I
mean the families were we're devastated
when they found out that what happened
to them didn't happen in isolation you
know that there were other families who
had experienced the same thing no family
more devastated than the Eskimo yes
doctor came
egos you know missing Escamilla you know
I just know something about I really
hate to tell you but your daughter just
suffered a stroke
[Music]
I just remember looking at I just burst
out crying
the reporters uncovered one
heartbreaking case after another yeah in
many ways these were families who didn't
have a voice and in particular they
didn't have a voice alone you know but
when they came together they had much
more of a voice the full Tampa Bay Times
investigative report told a story that
some in the hospital had tried to keep
quiet you know it was only a few weeks
before they made pretty system-wide
changes to the hospital the CEO resigned
we saw three vice presidents resign two
surgeons left the hospital two heart
surgeons the chairman of surgery stepped
down from that post although he remains
at the hospital and the new hospital
President issued a remarkable apology to
the families and the employees who had
tried to blow the whistle I know
personally that many of you courageously
spoke out when you had concerns but were
ignored or turned away that behavior is
unacceptable and will not be tolerated
going forward and most importantly we
know an apology to the families and
patients who did not receive the
high-quality care that is our promise to
all patients I am deeply sorry for their
tragic losses it is devastating when a
child is harmed or life is lost for the
two reporters the profuse Hospital
apology served as a confirmation that
they were right to pursue the story in
the first place and they say there is
still more to do in a statement to us
that Johns Hopkins all Children's
Hospital said federal inspectors have
now removed the finding of patients
being in immediate jeopardy that all
deficiencies have been addressed so our
shout-out tonight to Cathleen mcgrory
and Neil Divi and the editors at the
Tampa Bay Times for taking on one of the
country's most prestigious medical
institutions and producing the kind of
journalism that challenges the
established and the powerful that's our
program for
right thanks for joining us we'll see
you here next week